Clive Bixby.
What a sexy surprise.
Quick question did it hurt when you fell from
heaven because you fell?
I'm going to come in again.
We are watching Baby Joe on Valentine's Day,
so my dad and Gloria can.
Make love. Ew don't.
The point is, we are celebrating a day
early.
So they can finally be intimate.
More than made that point.
I'm just saying it's a long wait.
After giving birth six weeks, I couldn't
keep my hands off this one for that long.
I can only imagine what Jay is going
through. Voila.
Square knot impressive.
I can make any kind of knot.
It's like I have a sailor in my mouth.
I should check on the kids.
Haley took him to the movies. She's not even
going to answer.
I know, but, sweetie, I have a good reason to
worry. Luke had that nasty nosebleed this
morning, and Alex, as usual, fainted.
She's fine. And Dunphy, men get nosebleeds.
I told you this when we got married.
It was in my vows.
I'm still a little
unclear as to why you put that in the-
Shhh!
You finish that drink, pretty lady.
We got a big night ahead of us.
Okay. First we have a date with a romance.
A threesome, if you will.
From here, we move on to an old fashioned
blimp nick.
Now, is that the one where the man has to
face out with the woman?
It's a picnic on a blimp.
Huh? Champagne, cheese.
And this beautiful city beneath us.
Actually, sounds really romantic.
After that, we swap our earplugs for some
earmuffs, take a few moonlit turns around
the local ice rink.
Oh.
From there, it's a quick trip back to the
hotel where I'm spinning.
Oh, I wouldn't start with that, but, uh, we
can work our way up to it.
No, I'm
feeling really weird.
You can't shock live.
Just tell me what you want.
Juliana. Claire, one of you needs to answer
me.
Blood pressure. Still good.
I think I can send you home.
Great. So it's probably just low blood sugar
or something. See, honey, I told you it was
nothing to worry about.
Well, it's not nothing.
You did have a small heart episode.
Doctor Coleman, this may have been my fault.
I think I was being too sexy.
Yeah, I don't think that's an issue.
Are you sure about that?
Um.
Doctor, you're not saying that I had a heart
attack or something, right?
Not at all. What you have is a very minor
arrhythmia known as Wolff-parkinson-white
syndrome. It's hereditary.
So you're off the hook.
Oh, yeah. My mom has that.
We'll treat it with medication and have you
back in a couple of days.
In the meantime, just take it easy, okay?
Thank you.
Guess we should tell your dad we can't watch
the baby tomorrow.
No, no, I don't want everyone to know about
this. They're just going to get worried and
make a bigger deal of it than it is.
Sweetheart. Promise me.
I promise I know it's not that big a deal.
This is a huge deal.
For which I'm partly responsible, in spite
of what Claire's lesbian doctor says.
Hey, honey, I was just reading about this
wolf white thing. It's not that serious.
You're gonna be fine, I know.
Who's ready to hit the ice?
What? Come on.
Somebody promised me a moonlit skate.
But didn't the doctor say you needed to take
it easy?
It's just one of those things they have to
say. Like you can't drink when you're
pregnant. Come on.
We're not going to seriously blow off
Valentine's Day, are we?
No. I just thought, why ice things down when
we could heat things up?
Oh, I like where this is going.
Yeah.
Right. Yes.
No, honey, I know what you're doing.
You're treating me like a patient, and you
promise that you.
No no no no no no no, I just had a better
idea. What?
Side by side couples massage, huh?
Just you, me and a couple Cambodian guys to
work us over good.
Specific. What is that?
You think the kids are home?
I sounds like more than our three.
Oh, well, they think we're not home and
they're having a party.
I'm killing them. No no no no no.
No no no no. A, it's my turn to kill them.
B, you need to order up those massages.
It's under best number one U.S.A.
Coca-Cola good time massage.
What the hell is going on?
Dad, what are you doing home?
So this is how it is. We're going for a
minute, and you guys throw a party?
No. Just texting mom, we're having a good
time at the movies. Works every tim-
So this is a regular thing?
No, you know the drill.
Coolers out back- Enough.
Turn off the music.
Everybody who I did not create.
Get out of my house right now!
I want to get upset.
I've been through enough tonight.
What happened?
I'm not supposed to tell you when you say it
like that.
We make it worse in our heads.
Fine. It's no big deal.
Your mother had to go to the hospital.
Oh my God, that is so much worse than it
would be in our heads.
She's fine. She just passed out.
A little something to do with her heart.
Oh, like
a heart attack?! Mom had a heart attack!?
Mom almost died of a heart attack?
No, she had a little episode.
Probably triggered by me.
She just needs to rest.
For once let's not think about ourselves.
Phil. Everything okay?
It's fine. I'm coming.
Just act like everything's normal.